ですから 昔のやり方だけ言うならば
やっぱりこの教えてもらう人のところで生活するんですね
一緒に 生活して そこは何年かっていうことは先生の方が決めるんですね
自分の性格っていうのは自分には見えないもんなんですね
人間というのは自分こそ正しくて世界一と思っているんでしょうし
ですから 自分の短所はいくら何でしょうかと聞いたっても
本人はわからないんですね
あるわけないんだと 自分が完璧だというのは
普通の人々はみんなそうなんですね
ですから 自分を瞑想法っていうのは自分で選べと言ったらね
選べないんですね というわけで
先生のところに行って住み込むと
住み込んだところで 先生にはどういう人間かということは明確に見えるんですね
そこでちゃんと性格の方はね
ものの判断 見方 考え方
生き方 わかったところで
じゃあこういう瞑想をしなさいと言うんですね
それからの指導もできるんですね
人のことをよくわかっているんだから
この過程に 瞑想の過程においてどんな問題作るか
どんなトラブルを作るかっていうことも一応わかっているんだから
責任を持って指導できるんですね
それは昔のやり方 そういうことで
一応基本的に瞑想を指導する専門家のために
性格分析っていうものはアビダンマでできているんですね
この性格分析っていうのは
こういうのは一般的に人々に使うことはできないんです
日常生活する中で あなたはこんな性格
あなたはこんな性格とかね
そういうふうなことで人を差別するために使うことは不可能なんですね
一応基本的には六つに性格を分けていますから
ラーガチャリタ ドーサチャリタ
モーハチャリタ サンカーラチャリタ
ヴィタッカチャリタ ブッディチャリタという六つに分けてますけど
その六つも仏教において瞑想を指導するという
あるいは自分の個人の悟りということを考えた上で
その個人がどの方法で悟れるかという特別な目的があって
その性格分析しているんです
ですから ぴったし自分でわかったと
私はどんな性格かっていうのはね
そんなもう簡単にわかるわけじゃないんですね
で わかったと言っちゃったら
もうそこはいろいろ合わない
そうやって誤解する しようとするんだからね
一応読んでもわからないように書いてるんですね
なぜかというと 欲の性格
ラーガチャリタ 貪欲の人の性格は何ですかとリストがあるんです
それで なるほど 見当たるところあるなと思ったところで
信仰の性格のところ次に書いている
次ではなくて 後で書いている
なるほど見当たるところあるんだと
ほとんど同じことを書いているんです
欲の性格と信の信仰の性格っていうのはぴったし合うように書いているんです
それで 怒りに基づいて性格の人の性格と
ものすごく物事を考える
そういうすごく物事をよく考える人の性格もぴったしダブるように書いているんですね
じゃあ選んでみろと ですから
この 無知の性格と知恵の性格はぴったし合わせているんです
だからそれはもう専門家でないと
仏教の世界の真理を知っている人でいないと限りしないと
なかなか普通の人々にはわからなくなって
それは仏教のことを閉鎖的ということではなくて
公に言っちゃえばいいんじゃないかということでは
それは難しさなんですね
そういうことで 一つ瞑想について誰によろしいですかということは
私はこの四十種類の瞑想の教えて説明した場合は言ったと思ってはいるんです
そのその場合で そこでなんですけど
ですから 一応今日の部分はなくても構いません
一応ダブりますけどね
チャリタースパナ ダサ アスバーカーヤガターサティ サンカータ コッターサ バワナーチャ ラーガチャリタサ サッパーヤ
ラーガ・チャリタっていうのは貪笑者でしょうかね
むさぼり貪笑者という人については
ダサアスブハナ 10種類の不浄の瞑想
あれは遺体見て瞑想することですね
それからカエガタサティというのは体を三十二に分けて
三十二の臓器ですか 体の部分に分けて分けて見る瞑想ですね
そうやってコッタ・アスブハナ
部分 いわゆる解剖して瞑想するということなんですね
で この解剖的に瞑想することは
貪瞋痴の人にとってはよろしいんじゃないかなと
言ってます だから問題は自分が本当に貪笑かないか
自分ではわからないはずなんですね
正直な人だったらわからないわけでもないんで
正直で物事を観察できるようになったところで
自分の心をね もう客観的に見たら自分が何者かと見るとわかるんですけど
やっぱりそれ難しいんですね
ずっと自分は正しいんだという立場にいるんだからね
それでなかなか難しいんですね
我々は何とどういういかなる恥ずかしいことを
バカバカらしいことをしたっても
まあその時はそれ まあその時はもうぴったりそれ正しいと思っているし
で 後でまずいんだとわかっても
とにかくだってそういうわけでやったんではないかということで理由を作るんですね
まあそういうことだから
自分の心を見られるということはまあ不可能なんですね
まあ例えばそれで じゃあ貪笑の人やと自分でも知って
あるいは先生にも言われたとする
じゃあだからいきなり不浄の瞑想はいいっていうことですかね
こちらで書いてるんだからって
それはいいっていうわけじゃないんです
そこものすごく難しいんです
これはもう学生の人々も
当時の学生でいたって仏教の世界では十四歳
十五歳ぐらいのガキたちでしたから
まあそちらにも基本のことを覚えてもらうために言ってるだけのことなんです
本当はそうじゃないんです
これはこの百パーセント正真正銘の貪笑
まあ欲しか何もない というこの完璧な病気になるほど貪笑の人なんですね
人を見ると頭の中で自分の性的な欲
欲望を満たすためにふさわしいかないか
ただそれだけの判断する人間やと
犬同士動物同士そういうでしょうし
だからこの動物の中でオスがメスを見たら調べるんですけど
これはまあ交尾できるかないかと
それだけの尺度なんですね
交尾できるだったらもうそこで仲良くしようとする
できないんだったら無関心でもう帰っちゃう
その動物の種によりますけど
時々凶暴になって 攻撃までする
時々は興味ないと帰っちゃう
だからまあそれぐらいの頓症だったら
まあ解剖してあの体を見た方がいいということなんですね
でもそこまで病気な人には瞑想はまず不可能でしょうし
だからそれはそんなに甘い話じゃないんです
瞑想しようと弟子入りしようとする人は
そんな単純じゃないんです
そこもいちいち覚えておいてほしいんですね
次にあったのは何でしたっけ
怒りの性格の人にはチャタッソーアッパマンヤーヨ
慈悲喜捨の四つの瞑想はよろしいと
それからこの色を見てニールピートロヒトーダータという
この青い 赤い 黄色い 白いという色を四つを見て瞑想する瞑想ありますね
そういうものも怒りの人にはよろしいんだと
で その中でもその人の怒りの特色によって
あなたは青いでいようと
あなたは赤色でいようと
あなたは白色でいようと
これ先生が決めなくちゃいけないんですね
慈悲喜捨の場合も 慈にするか悲にするか喜にするか捨にするかと
それもその人の怒りの働きによって決めなくちゃいけないもんなんですね
だからまあ そういう風にこの人間というのは
四角いか丸いか三角かっていう風に決めようとしている
このアビダルマの働きも
まあそんな正しいとは私は思ってないんですね
そこで注釈書とかね もっと古いこちらに元になったテキストを見ても
はっきり説明していないし
はっきりしてないんです
一応性格分析というのは
アビダルマの七つのテキストの中で一冊なんですね
ここでずっとやっているのはこの一冊の内容なんですね
一冊 二冊ぐらいの内容なんですね
うん まあ逆にこの慈悲喜捨の瞑想っていうのは
まあこれと別に まあ仏教では万人がやらなくちゃいけない瞑想としておっしゃっているものですから
それにはあまり性格関係はないんです
ですから まあまあ 本当はアビダンマアビダンマッタサンガハのレベルでしか喋ってはいけませんだけど
このもうもっと上のレベルのアビダルマの方はね
あまり言わない方がいいと思いますけど
混乱する可能性ありますからね
一応言い始めたら止まりませんし
で 慈悲喜捨の瞑想はこちらでこう書いてますけど
慈悲喜捨っていうのは万人はやらなくちゃいけない瞑想であって
まあそれ仏教の立場なんですね
それは仏教であろうがなかろうがもう関係なく
人間であるならば他人に対して親切にするのは当たり前ではないかと
あんたは生きていきたいでしょうと
生きていきたいんだったら
他人に親切にしなさいと
死にたければ他人に他人のことをね
嫉妬したり憎しんだりしたっても
それはもうどうせ死にたい人だからね
まあ構いませんだけどね
死にたい人はもう他人に迷惑をかけながら生きていようと思わないんですね
死にたい人はすぐ死んじゃいますから
だから 他人に迷惑までかけて
他人に嫉妬したり 憎しんだり
恨んだりしてまで生きていきたいんですね
それだったらバカなことをするなと
矛盾なことをするなと
生きていきたければ 他人に親切になるのは頭のいい人の常識な
頭のいいというよりは
それは常識だよというのが仏教の立場ですから
慈悲喜捨の瞑想っていうのは万人がやらなくちゃいけないものなんです
その中でも慈悲喜捨だから瞑想四つなんですね
で なぜ瞑想四つかというと
心の中でこの四種類の感情を引き起こすんですね
生命に対する四種類の感情
友情の感情 罰苦の感情
それから喜びの感情と
平安な心で見守る感情という
見守ってあげようと放っておきましょうという感情ですね
あまり漆黒と他人に関わる持たないようにしましょうと
という人の自由を認める感情なんですね
だからウペッカーですか
捨っていうのは いろんな立場で説明しなくちゃいけない
大変理解しにくしにくいものなんですね
例えば生命ってみんな平等ではないかと
いちいち私はああだこうだとかね
そういうせっかちなことなんて言いますか
そんなおせっかいしなくてもいいんではないかと
ということで 人のことを大きな心で認めてみる
まあ放っておくといえばちょっと失礼ない言葉かもしれませんだけど
まあ大変大きな目で見守っていると
それも大変必要なことで
人間にはなかなかそれもできない
すぐもう感情湧いてきますね
例えば自分が電車に乗って
車両の向こう側のところで
なんか人がなんか変な何かやってるんだと
変なことをしているんだと
それは目に入った途端
こちらでいら立ちやらいろいろ感情が生まれてくるんだから
自分に関係ないんだからね
放っておけばいいんですけどね
それやっぱりできないと
そこでじゃあ関係ないんだから見ないふりをしましょうと思っても
そこでそれでももう自分が苦労しているんですね
だから心できている人は
まあなんとか理解するんですね
それはまあ その人の立場から見れば
それはどうったことないでしょうと
ですから 慈悲喜捨っていうのは
そうやって万人にふさわしい瞑想であって
これは怒りの性格の人にふさわしいという風には言い切れないものなんですね
逆にこちらでいうのは
怒りのいつでも怒りっぱなしの人は何をするべきかというと
やっぱり慈悲喜捨の瞑想ぐらいでもした方がいいんじゃないかなということになっちゃいますね
それでも怒りの種類によって瞑想を変えなくちゃいけないんですね
それから 万人がその瞑想する場合も
自分が慈悲喜捨の一つを選んでやった方が
一応効き目は早いんですね
その場合はアビダンマでは言っているのは
このものすごいこの耐える方法というか
このアグレッシブ方法なんですね
攻撃的なやり方なんですね
で 私はそれだけで攻撃的なやり方だけでは効き目があるかないかと
また考えてはいますけどね
まあそれにもお釈迦様の例はありますけどね
で 攻撃的なやり方っていうのは
これインド的なインドの普通の教育方法に基づいている文化的な背景も入ってるんですね
インドの教育って インド文化の教育っていうのはやっぱりアグレッシブなんですね
攻撃的なんですね 例えば先生が喋ると
生徒は黙って聞かなくちゃいけないんだったら黙って聞けと
それ以上はダメなんです
で はい 喋りなさいと言ったら喋らなくちゃいけないんですね
そう 他のことはもう認めない
立ちなさいと言ったら立つ
座れと言ったら座ると
で それで逆に生徒も先生が言ったことには異論があるんだよと
言ったら堂々とアグレッシブに異論は出せる
異論を出しちゃったら
先生はなんであんたはあんた生徒のくせに生徒の身分で何？ということはできません
先生もアグレッシブですから
自分が言ったことを正しいかな
は弁論しなくちゃいけない
負けたらもう負けをちゃんと認める
自分が間違ったならば
そういうすごいアグレッシブやり方で
攻撃的なやり方で 対立型というかね
そういうふうにこの文化の中で成り立ってるんですね
別に大きく見たら大したことないんだけど
インドの世界 インド文化の世界もハイハイハイな世界かもしれませんだけど
中国文化も同じなんですけども
全部軍隊みたいにみんなハイハイで生きてますけどね
でもこちらでは この人間本来持ってるアグレッシブの性格はどこで処理するかっていうことはないんですね
で それは自分でギューッと抑えて一生ストレスで苦しむか
ものすごい大胆な行動をやって殺戮者になるか
どっちかなんです というふうなこともありますね
だからモンゴル系の人っていうのは
戦争になったらものすごい凶暴で
もう何の道徳もなく殺すということもあるんですよ
し 逆に落ち着くと まあすごい言うことはもう完璧に聞くというものもあるしね
ですから そういうのははっきりというふうに言えるものではなくて
大雑把な言い方だからね
まあなんとなくそういうふうにも性格あるっていうぐらいのことで
ガエト じゃあインド文化はそれでどうですかというと
これまた同じ問題なんですね
もう元々アグレッシブだから
一応自分の攻撃性っていうのはいつでも攻撃されてますから
そこで取り消されているんですね
もし取り消されなかったならば
どこまででもこのアグレッシブという性格が
攻撃性が成長するんです
そこをインド文化の人々はあまり戦争にはいかないんだけど
それは宗教文化で抑えているんだからね
でも喧嘩になったらどこまで行くかとわからないんですね
で コントロールできないんですね
で 逆にアグレッシブな方法で抑えなくちゃいけない
そう 慣れてるんです それに
自分が腹が立ってきたら
向こう側も腹が立って攻撃しない限りはこれ消えないと
消えたら二人がまた仲良くっていうことになっちゃうんで
ずーっと恨み持ってるっていうことでもないんです
例えばインドでイスラム教の人とヒンドゥー教の人はものすごく仲が悪くて
時々もう爆発しちゃうんですね
まあ教会を燃やしちゃうわ
人を殺すわとかね 何のことなく
ただ単に宗教違うだけで引っ張って殺すということもやっちゃうんですね
それやりながらまた仲良くなったら
まあ二人で一緒にご飯食べたり
もういろいろ商売やったり
またやってるんですね
そこでもし腹が立ったら
もう一緒に商売してる二人かもしれませんだから
むったくらに殺し合いやっちゃう
だからもうそれは外国人にとってはなかなかわからないかもしれませんね
そういう性格は そこで例えばある村でイスラム教とヒンドゥー教がすごくお互いに喧嘩しているんだと
暴動起こして殺し合いやってるんだよと思ったら
で 店があるんだよ 店が誰がやってるんだ？イスラム教の人が店がやっていて
インドのヒンドゥー教の人々ばっかりそこで買い物して
お客さんがそればっかりということもまたあるんですね
その人から品物を買ってイスラム教の人々を殴りに行くということもあるんです
だからまあ どういう性格かということは
外国文化の人にとってはわからないかもしれませんですけどね
まあそうやってこのどちらがいいということは言いにくいんだけど
人間には癖がつきますから
とにかくインド文化っていうのはかなりアグレッシブというふうなことで
教育システムはね できてるんですね
それで結果としては最終的には平和を作ると
で 政党を育てる場合はとことんこのもう攻撃的で教えてあげて
それで政党も先生に対して攻撃しながらやって
そこで一人前になったところで
もう先生のことはもう命の恩人として尊敬するんです
あの攻撃も全部やがて消えちゃうんです
消えると先生は政党としてはなくて
一人前の立派な人として認めるし
その人は一人前だよと言ってあげるんだけど
その人はやっぱり私を育てたのはこの先生だよということで
まあ親として一生尊敬していくんですね
先生はたとえボケて何もできなくて寝たきりになっても
尊敬することだけはやめませんね
まあそれで全てもう面倒まで見てあげると
先生の子供に見放されても
政党には見放されることはないんです
政党はもう付きっきりで面倒見てあげるという風なぐらい
もう最終的な結果はそういう結果にもなりますけどね
一応希望としても まあそういう希望で
そこでこのアグレッシブ教育だから
怒りに対してアグレッシブ的な態度っていうのは慈しみなんですね
欲に対してアグレッシブ的な立場っていうのは
醜い 汚いというふうに見ることなんです
だからこの全く正反対の感覚
感情を受け入れて 前の感情を壊すと
いわゆるゼロにすると
で まあこの瞑想の世界では
このゼロの原理はものすごく働いてますから
まず人間にはネガティブ感情がいっぱいあるということでね
それにはこの全く反対の数学的で考えてるんだからね
マイナス３だったら このマイナス３をなくしちゃいいんだったら
やっぱりプラス入れないと
プラス３入れないとゼロにならないんですね
そういうことで怒りに対して慈しみという風になってくる
欲に対して不浄ということはなってくるんですね
それすごくアグレッシブ的なやり方で
まあインド文化の人にとってはこういう説明っていうのはよくわかりやすいんです
だから怒り あの怒りの性格の人にとっては慈悲喜捨という風に決めてます
でもこのアグレッシブ方法だけで人は成長するという決まりはないんです
例えばいたずらする子供がいるとする
先生は暴力振ると それでさらに悪くなる可能性もあります
あるいは勉強は失敗してうまく理解しないと
あんたバカではないかとか
言ったらすごく落ち込んで
本当にバカになってしまうこともありますしね
だから必ずしもアグレッシブ方法効くということはないんです
じゃあ逆な方法必ず効きますから
そうでもないんですね
たとえ授業勉強しないで失敗ばっかりしても大丈夫
大丈夫ね それぐらいのことで頑張ればよくできますよと
褒め 褒め殺しに行くと
日本風に それでうまくいくということでもないんですね
だから例えば日本の教育システムというのは
そういう褒め殺しやり方ですけどね
まあだからって言って完璧ということでもないしね
ですから そういうこの教育世界っていうのは
いつでもケースバイケースでいかなくちゃいけない
ですから すごく難しいことなんですね
で 私の話を聞く人々も
まあ正真正銘の無知な人々っていうのは
いつでもはっきり言ってくれと
これこれにどっちか これにどっちかと
そこだけメモを書いていて
それで相手をぶん殴ろうと思ってるんですね
ですから この例えば子供が親と喧嘩すると
仏教ではどうすればいいんですか？と
そんなものに答えがあるわけないでしょうに
それはケースバイケースだから
例えば何々さんの家庭でなんとかという長男か次男かそれもありますよ
次男にしたっても上の子は次男といったら上の子は男ですけど
例えば真ん中の子供やと2番目の子供だと2番目の子供の上が男か女かということによっても変わりますよ
親と喧嘩しているのは2番目の子供だと 1番目は女の子やと言ったらそのケースと
いや 1番目を男やというその時もケースは違うでしょうし
そこで親と親の子供に対する態度というものによって
また答えが変わっちゃうでしょうしね
だから中道という知恵がない限りはね
その答えが見つからないんですね
そこで我々は自分の心を直すんじゃなくて
人に説教してやろうという気持ちで
もうどういうどうすればいいんですかと
この普遍的に人の性格の場合
どうすればいいかっていうふうなことで答え聞くんだけど
そういう答えはないんですね
普遍的に喋れる真理は別にあります
それから人の生き方になると
やっぱりその場合は実践の世界になるとケースバイケースでいかなくちゃいけないんですね
そういうことで 私たちは思うよりすごい知恵
仏教は必要としてるんですね
仏教の世界では ものすごい心の大きさと余裕と包容力というもの
理解能力 すごく必要とするんですね
それから新しい知恵を発達するために
心の余裕というもの ものすごく必要なんです
ずっと汗っぱりの人生で時計に振り回されてる人生では知恵が発達しないんですね
いつでも心はリラックスしておいて
余計なことをくだらないこと
どうでもいいこと 考えなくてもいいことを考えないで
心の余裕な時間を心を楽しませておいてとかね
そうすると新しいアイディアがいくらでも
生まれてくるんですね
で 今日は遅くなったのはあの
ちょっとテキストの訂正やってましたから
終わりまで これ一人でやるんだったら二人でやりましたからね
あの途中であめてもいいんだけど
だから終わるまでやって
そこでいくつかのところを書き換えたんです
それを話した時は そのその日で前の日で世の中で起きた出来事をいくつか私は例に出してやったんです
まだ話してから 1年経ってはないんですけど
あれ読んだら あ こんな古臭いことを言ったって
これ変えなくちゃいけないと
もし私の頭はすごいぎっしりと石に刻んだように硬いものだったら
まあまあその通りでいいんじゃないかということになります
やっぱり心にはいつでも新しいアイディアが生まれて
古いアイディアが消えていかないと
新鮮さというのはもうなくなっちゃうんですね
そういうことも理解してほしいんです
怒りの性格の人には自律車どちらがいいかということは
先生が決めていった方がもっとやりやすいし
逆に怒りが成長するということになっちゃうと
例えば他人に対してもすごく怒っているし
幸せでありますようにと思っちゃうと
どんどんもっと腹が立ってきて
もう我慢できないということにもなりますね
そうなってくると 指導者がね
そこを直せちゃうんですね
そこで万人にふさわしい瞑想として説明している
書いてるところでは この万人に怒りをなくすような方法で説明しているんです
そういう方法いろいろありますからね
それから色の場合も やっぱりどんな色もいいというわけでもないんですね
例えばニイラという青い色を見ていると
普通の世の中の心理が絡むことで暗くなる可能性ありますね
ですから 人はちょっと激しい性格だったら青い色はいいかもしれません
普段もなんとなくもう咲いてない人やと言ったら
やっぱり青い色はまずいでしょうと思いますね
それだったら赤い色か白い色かに決めなくちゃいけないし
それは一つ決める方法で
もう一つは自分にぴったし気に入るかいらないかと
そこは先生はもう色を見ると
この人のこのかすかな反応で判断しなきゃいけないんです
はっきり見ると誰でも見えますから
見た瞬間のものすごいかすかな反応があるんです
そのかすかな反応で見なくちゃいけないんです
だから長い間一緒に生活すると
この人は青い色には反応するんだと
いわゆる心惹かれるということなんですね
例えば全部色を四つ全部並んで見せても
本人の脳の中で一つに先に反応しちゃうんです
一つの色に それだったらそれ選んであげる
そうすると集中しやすいし
瞑想は成長しやすいんですよ
でもどれほど早いかというとね
これはもう機械でも測れないんでしょう
そういうことで あの いくらか
あの 何て言いますか 一緒に生活すると
まあそれぐらいのことはわかります
例えばお寺だったらね
まあいろいろ色のいろいろものがあるとする
それ片付けて置いてくださいと
と何か命令する これ片付けなさい
それだけなんです すごい厳しく言うんです
その場合は仕事をさせてるだけで
本人がまあただまあまたもう一仕事やらせているんだということで
嫌な気持ちでやってるかもしれませんだけど
すぐ瞬時に見たら先に手がどこに行ったかと
これも一秒の百分の一でも終わっちゃうんですね
すぐ見える 手が先にどんな色のものに行ったかと
そこで終わらないで またまた何回も試してみる
花を取ってこいと これからお釈迦様に花差し上げ
花を差し上げなくちゃいけないと
それでどんな色の花が多いですか？とかね
そこで見えるし で そこで判断できなかったら
じゃああんたきちんとこれ整理して置きなさいと言ったら
その人は先にどんな花取るか
先に違う色の花が取っても
どんな色でハイライト作るかとかね
そういうふうなことでもうわかってしまうんですね
なぜならば花を整理する場合は
その人のイメージで作っているんだから
その人が感動するイメージ作るんだから
そこである花である色でこのハイライト作っちゃうでしょ
ね そういう風に決めるんですね
そこで知識型と かね 知識型というか
よく物事を考える人とかね
知恵の人だったらまた違うやり方やっちゃうんで
それはどう判断するかというと
ある日は青い色でハイライトを作ったんだけど
次の日は赤い色でハイライトすると
その次の日は全部真っ白で決めると
なかなかどんな色かとわからなくなっちゃうんだと
ということは その人は色ではなくて
毎回毎回何か違う作品を作ろうではないかという頭を働かしているんですね
この人は怒り型ではなくて
まあ知恵型とかね まあ知識型とかどっちかでしょうという風になっちゃうんです
それでこのアーナパーナはモーホチャリタス
アーナパーナっていうのは
呼吸瞑想は無知の知性の人と
それから人 よく物事を考える人によろしいんだと
仏随念などの仏随 仏 法
僧 神とかね 随念瞑想 アヌッサティ瞑想ありますね
そういうのは信証の人々
サッダーチャリタですね
それから死の瞑想 解脱の瞑想とかね
それからこの分別瞑想
地水火風の世の中分別して見る瞑想は
どうせそれは分かりやすい
これは知恵の性格の人にとてもいいことなんですね
まあそこら辺はまあ大体攻撃的ではないんです
そこら辺はその通りだと思います
ここで言わなかった瞑想っていうのが 40種類ありますからね
言わなかったものは大体誰にでも合いますよと
ああいうのこの高井さんのチャートにあったんですか
まあチャートにありますので
で そこ だからこちらではこの
そうやってチャートにはもう分けてますけど
これ他の人に全くそれは合わないというわけではないんです
例えば仏随念はもう信証者ですよと
という風に じゃあ他の人やったらいけないかって
そういうことではないんで
例えばあの覚証者ですか
仏智の知恵の人 知恵の人には知恵があるんだけど
信が足らないという場合は
もう性格を直さなくちゃいけないんだから
やっぱりそこをやらなくちゃいけないんで
そうやってこの まあ選んで
またいろいろ分けて分けてやることもやります
それからヴィタッカチャリタ
尋 尋証というのはなかなか統一性ないんですね
だからサマーディはなかなか難しいんです
だから尋証者が例えば
まあ尋証者にはパティヴィアポーという座位をかしこやれば統一性は生まれるし
そういうなんとか瞑想しなくちゃいけないんです
とにかく まあそういうことで
まあチャート見れば明確にわかるだろうと思います
でも私のポイントは明確にわかっては困ると
そういうふうに分けられませんということなんです
でもこの基本なければ
また返って瞑想は修行することもできませんしね
だからこの攻撃性良くないというストーリーがありまして
このあるあの金の作業するこのアクセサリー作る職人がいて